well could a man accused of killing a
woman and then hiding her body in the
desert strike a plea deal the eight news
now investigators have been following
the case again Christopher prestepino
for more than three years once again
things are really heating up Vanessa
Murphy has the latest twist and we do
want to warn you some of the details in
this report are disturbing
Christopher prestapino saying he's open
to a plea deal and trying to blame the
murder on his former co-defendant
negotiations but the negotiations are
are giving the killer better into the
deal
and we have proof and statements that
that's saying that she says you're good
he's accused of killing 24 year old
Esmeralda Gonzalez putting her body in
cement and then the desert in 2019.
detectives say he gave her meth at his
Southwest Valley Home tied her up and
strangled her and then he and his
roommate Cassandra Garrett injected her
with pool cleaner they originally faced
the same charges including murder court
records show Garrett took a plea deal
remains in custody and will be sentenced
later this month an amended indictment
reveals a charge for voluntary
manslaughter with use of a deadly weapon
in this letter to the judge obtained by
the 8 news now investigators Garrett
writes in part I not only accept
responsibility for the charges of which
I am guilty she claims she agonizes over
what she could have or should have done
but she doesn't seem to admit to killing
Gonzalez and then there's also
prestepino's girlfriend I'm waiting for
you and you're the only one in my
personal name
yeah
I love you too Lisa Mort pleaded guilty
to accessory to murder in 2020 and she's
already been released from prison the 8
news now investigators previously
obtained phone calls while she was in
jail and prestapino was out on bond
before he failed to show up for a court
date and was taken back into custody
I've been
now more than three years after his
arrest prestopino claims he doesn't feel
ready for his murder trial citing a lack
of communication from his attorney while
lawyer Craig Mueller says they are ready
he says he'll try to work with
prosecutors for possible negotiations
over the next 24 hours Vanessa Murphy 8
News Now